hey good humans welcome to another
episode of spectrum this is michael
hello i'm ian and uh stick around at the
end we're going to talk a little bit
with you guys
believing men and believing women same
level no no disagree
i have in the court of law the quran
explicitly states
two female witnesses carry the weight of
one male and that's why i stood over
[Music]
there
i pray five times a day three
two one
i wish i was there with you guys like
it's
honestly it just gets really hard like
it's just five times a day it's like
spread throughout the day
we all live like young professional
lives and it gets kind of in the way
if i could quantify it i'm averaging
about three out of five prayers
i think i will find myself in prayer
more when i'm in desperation
it's not something that's subjective i
know we should be all praying as a
requirement
i just want to say it takes a lot of
guts to be honest and say that
i honestly believe that if you feel it
in your heart
that you have a strong relationship with
god god will have mercy on you
with whatever you're dealing with so
being on this line doesn't mean it's
like
a piece of cake to do the five daily
prayers it is a struggle it's a
challenge i was working in a corporate
environment where i could not
comfortably find a space so i'd have to
go pray in the car and the parking lot
so it it is a challenge but yeah
[Music]
we're not allowed to cut down trees
during war we're not allowed to hurt
children and mothers we're not allowed
to hurt our own prisoners and when
people associate
terrorism something so disgusting with
islam
it hurts me because isis targets muslims
more than they target
anybody else and in the age of google
there's no excuse
like if you don't know that islam means
peace
islam means surrender being a muslim is
one who submits
their will to god how is that violent
like at the end of the day i feel like
media is the one that
has that hand and that stronghold
causing
folks to be that way or think that way
i guess i literally listened to the
prompts does islam
promote violence and i'm only speaking
not from my personal perspective but
just
from trying to understand how
discussions about this religion can be
used to defame it
to justify terrorism per se when
somebody says and
you know for the record kill a
non-believer let's acknowledge that
sentence
and if we're going to reach a conclusion
and a solution with somebody who does
think
this way of us and our faith we need to
understand their argument thoroughly but
i disagree with what you just said
i really do because i read the quran
every day as a practice
and not once in 2019 have i yet
gotten to a verse about violence all of
them about mercy of god
turn to god god is with you to me
that's that is an emotional connection
to my creator
sure and i'm not going to allow anybody
to take that away i'll take what you
would the sentence the statement that
you could kill the non-believers
at the time of the holy prophet the
muslims were in danger they were the
minority rights
so but that but it doesn't necessarily
mean that because we are in danger that
whenever there's a non-believer
we kill them what non-believer uh refers
to
are like the meccans or like the people
that were actively going against muslims
right
trying to harmless and i wanted this
healthy discourse yes
because i dwell upon that other
perspective i did i didn't grow up proud
of those verses because i didn't
understand them
yeah and now that i do have full
understanding i know that it's
important to keep not a one-dimensional
perspective but
not even accept the others but
thoroughly understand it
the job should be mandatory three
two one
i have strong feelings i just feel like
it's a woman's right to cover if she
wants to and to tell a woman what to do
with her body
is totally against our islamic
principles so
you know being a guy here i just i just
made a really conscious decision to be
like somewhat agree because people don't
understand that hijab is like a concept
as far as like it's not just like the
actual head scarf islam really promotes
the idea of modesty and that's how you
get closer to god
and if you feel like having a head scarf
is a way for you to get closer to god
then so be it 100 agree with that
because it's not just a head scarf it's
your behavior it's a personality it's
how you treat your friends and your
neighbors yeah
for a lot of people the process is build
my courage my bravery and my confidence
and then
wear the scarf for me it was kind of
reverse i started with the scarf because
i knew that i was not going to build
that bravery unless i started wearing it
because when you put it on you start
acting different you start acting nicer
you're kinder because now you're
representing your religion your faith
you make me think really deep about that
because i've been struggling i've been
struggling
i wore it when i was about 15 i tried it
out but it's been a struggle because
internally
i want to be a better muslim that i'm
going to represent to society
before my outer side represents islam
though i'm not a traditional muslim
female i don't wear the scarf
when i was younger i'd be walking home
from the masjid with my mom
she wears the hijab this was before
september 11th even happening
she would get teenagers and cars driving
by spitting on us
cursing at us she would always say just
brush it off
when you show that you're a muslim in
any way people kind of like you get
those glances every so often but what
happened was that
after like all this like election things
happen it's funny people who you grew up
with people who knew your entire lives
are kind of looking at you a little
differently
you know so that kind of threw me off a
little bit i was like wait a second like
you know me
i didn't think this would be an issue
you know i personally have not
experienced explicit discrimination
i conveniently can shave my beard and
try to compensate almost and it's
sad to admit but i know it's not my job
to create a comfort space for another
person
however i would say that if you do guys
confront it explicitly
try to think of it as an opportunity to
teach as opposed to reacting with
uh emotion i think it also depends on
what the encounter is like i had a beer
bottle thrown at me after 9 11.
i'm not going to go confront that person
be like hey let's build bridges right
like it's not
no but if there's someone who's got a
little bit of an attitude or you know
misconception
i'll work on that women
are equal to men three
two one
i'm gonna somewhat change mine
wow i had to think about it so the
reason i sit on agree and not strongly
agree
is that my my understanding of human
beings is that
that women and men in general have um
different roles
you know men cannot bear children women
do in in islam there's
no discriminatory thing there's nothing
that a man can do that a woman cannot
and i don't have to prove otherwise
except to cite in the quran when allah
addresses
us believing men and believing women
same level
no no disagree i have i read the
question
you can't tell me this in the court of
law the quran explicitly states
i'm sorry two female witnesses carry the
weight of one male and that's why i
stood over there i personally feel
and if it were up to me it would be 50
50. there is no discrimination on my
personal
uh bias but but i'm standing there i'm
acknowledging that the quran prescribes
something here right
no in islam we do get equal
opportunities
scientifically no we're not equal
because
men can do things physically that we
can't do
women can do things that men can't do so
my question would be
what aspect are we discussing personal
belief versus islamic belief versus
societal belief that's three different
things if i'm saying personally i
believe women can be greater than men i
believe women have
islam says that however
islam promotes that completely yeah
three two one
[Music]
it's such a broad question that i'm
gonna stand here just to be on the safe
side
i'm a contradictory human being i pray
with one hand and commit sin with the
other so i'm not in a position to be
able to
tell somebody that they're excluded from
my whole faith
if perhaps their faith in god is
stronger than mine
okay so you
you can be um anything and be a muslim
but i guess i guess the reason i'm
standing here is because
islam is a lot about the progression of
the human race
and about um about what is natural and
what is not
islam doesn't necessarily support like
the lifestyle of the lgbt community
however
they do support them as human beings and
that is something like um
you know something that i've struggled
with because
um they have my 100 love and support i
take a bullet for
anybody i don't care what their sexual
orientation is
my best friend he's um he's gay and
we've had these conversations before
and um he's told me that you know what
husna
i love you for you i love you for
everything that we've been through
together i don't care what it is that
you stand for and that's you know
it's it's it's really comforting to know
that you don't have to support a
lifestyle to support a human being to
love a human being
and to love people unconditionally i
love what you said
yeah and that's that's why i'm here
because
the prompt was can you be lgbtq and
muslim
and yes you can be anything and muslim
if we're going to get into the logistics
of lifestyle practices in the
the core of scripture yes there are
different lifestyles or things that are
asked for in scripture but there's
nothing that says they are not welcome
in the faith they are not welcome in our
houses of worship they cannot pray
they cannot stand beside us they don't
fast they are people
it's very hard i will say to be a muslim
and
you know part of the community
i agree with you beautiful statement
i am american three
two one
i swear i'm not trying to make this
controversial but i
somewhat disagree because i'm first
afghan then i would say i'm american
so i do identify as syrian first and so
what is america so for me that identity
because i grew up
not feeling like a minority and i was
always proud american i didn't talk
about my syrian heritage i wasn't
familiar with it
and then the last decade it was like
whoa i kind of whitewashed
my history to be the proud american to
fit in
and everyone was like if you took off
your scarf you'd be just another white
girl
it's just there's a battle like i'm
proud american but it's like what does
american mean right now
with everything that's happening as a
muslim who just happens to be black
in america i've never not known this to
be my country
because that's what this country was
founded on being
able to be who you are having the
freedom to be that
and not feel persecuted and so
yeah that's how i live my life and i'm
not going to let anybody
force me or talk me into thinking
differently
so who wants to have coffee and continue
this conversation yeah let's go to
starbucks
i love how you always bring up another
side to it
it's great it's great
so i have a question for you you've
directed every single episode of
spectrum
how do you go about finding out
like what prompts to ask yeah how do you
do that justice a lot of research goes
into these episodes we try to meet with
people from the group
to help us come up with the prompts we
also ask you for some prompts the way to
do that is you follow us on instagram
and when we ask you for prompts for
certain groups then you can contribute
thanks for watching you guys we'll see
you around and uh enjoy all the rest of
the the spectrum episodes to come
forever and ever and ever
forever see ya